one of the real downsides to having a
president like Donald Trump that throws
so many norms and conventions to the
wind enacts in the childish immature and
erratic way that he does is that it can
help normalize or rehabilitate former
presidents who also did things that
aren't particularly good and I've been
really careful to avoid this with george
w bush so for the last two-and-a-half
years when I've pointed out Wow Trump is
going beyond even the craziness of
george w bush in many ways i'm always
sort of careful to remind you that we
don't want to incorrectly rehabilitate
george w bush's image bush was a
terrible ignorant neocon war hawk as a
president but he had some common decency
in some basic human ways that donald
trump just completely lacks and in the
same way i had many disagreements with
barack obama on policy during the eight
years of Barack Obama's presidency
Obama's escalation of the drone war
Obama's war on whistleblowers Obama's
inability to make real progress on
immigration Obama starting from to make
a position on health care reform there's
a very long list of disagreements I had
on policy with Barack Obama but Barack
Obama was an intelligent thoughtful and
- my belief fundamentally genuine person
to the extent that you can know those
characteristics about a person when you
see them through the media and through
their actions as president of the United
States and Barack Obama recently wrote a
letter in response to the shootings in
El Paso and in Dayton Ohio and it is
just a glaring reminder of what we're
lacking right now which is a president
who behaves like an adult and Donald
Trump couldn't take it and was so
triggered by Barack Obama that even
though Obama didn't mention him in his
letter Trump immediately took to Twitter
to insult Barack Obama now this is no
Obama love letter okay it's just
something that reminded me of what we've
lost with Donald Trump as president
let's take a look at the letter which
most importantly for me points out some
of the obvious things that a president
should be saying but Donald Trump is not
Bhama saying quote Michelle and I grieve
with all the families in El Paso and
Dayton who endured these latest mass
shootings even if details are still
emerging there are a few things we
already know to be true
first no other nation on earth comes
close to experiencing the frequency of
mass shootings that we see in the United
States no other developed nation
tolerates the levels of gun violence
that we do every time this happens we're
told that tougher gun laws won't stop
all murders that they won't stop every
deranged individual from getting a
weapon and shooting innocent people in
public places but the evidence shows
that they can stop some killings they
can save some families from heartbreak
we are not helpless here and until all
of us stand up and insist on holding
public officials accountable for
changing our gun laws these tragedies
will keep happening second while the
motivations behind these shootings may
not yet be fully known there are
indications that the El Paso shooting
follows a dangerous trend troubled
individuals who embrace racist
ideologies and see themselves obligated
to act violently to preserve white
supremacy like the followers of Isis and
other foreign terrorist organizations
these individuals may act alone but
they've been radicalized by white
nationalist websites that proliferate on
the Internet
that means that both law enforcement
agencies and Internet platforms need to
come up with better strategies to reduce
the influence of these hate groups but
just as important all of us have to send
a clarion call and behave with the
values of tolerance and diversity that
should be the hallmark of our democracy
we should soundly rejected the mouths of
any of our leaders that feeds a climate
of fear and hatred or normalizes racist
sentiments leaders who demonize those
who don't look like us or suggest that
other people including immigrants
threaten our way of life or refer to
other people as subhuman or imply that
America belongs to just one certain type
of people such language isn't new it's
been at the root of most human tragedy
throughout history here in America and
around the world it's at the root of
slavery and Jim Crow the Holocaust the
genocide in Rwanda and ethnic cleansing
in the Balkans it has no place in our
politics and our public life and it's
time for the overwhelming majority of
Americans of goodwill of
every race and faith and political party
to say as much clearly and unequivocally
this is just obvious context that's
missing when we hear Republicans and
Trump talk about this no other country
has these gun violence problems no other
country country has the resistance
caused by stupid but well-funded talking
points that we do and secondly whether
it's Isis or these right-wing terrorists
it's the same mechanism of
radicalization and we have to call it
out as such and we have to call it
terrorism in all cases and by the way
just dripping from the letter is actual
empathy and consolation for people
something that Donald Trump seems
fundamentally just unable to achieve
instead having the instincts of going to
Puerto Rico after a hurricane and
shooting rolls of paper towels like
basketballs like a game and Donald Trump
was so triggered by this letter which
doesn't even mention him by name that he
immediately went to Twitter to insult
Barack Obama with a quote from Fox and
Friends quoting Brian Kilmeade on Fox
and Friends saying did George Bush ever
condemn President Obama after Sandy Hook
President Obama had 32 mass shootings
during his reign not many people said
Obama's out of control mass shootings
were happening before the president even
thought about running for president now
there's a number of problems with that
including that there have been hundreds
and hundreds of mass shootings under
Donald Trump but more importantly Obama
didn't even mention Trump in his letter
and Obama was trying to make changes
which he couldn't get done as simple as
background checks and this goes to
Donald Trump's insecurities more than
anything else and there's two sides to
this on the one hand just being able to
speak and write in complete sentences
distinguishes Barack Obama from Donald
Trump in really important ways but the
substance of the letter is also
something that Donald Trump is unwilling
or unable to put together I've said
before money can't buy class it's never
been more clear than right now but the
problem is that the longer Trump is in
office the longer that this becomes more
and more okay it shouldn't be startling
to us to see Oh a president that can
speak coherently and isn't personally a
hacking political enemies on Twitter and
is thinking big picture about social and
political issues it does surprise us
it's notable even for me and for people
in our audience Trump has been
normalized to a great degree and every
day that he's in office becomes more
normal in a sense there has to be a
purge that's bigger than just getting
rid of Trump having people like Jared
and Ivanka in positions of power has
been normalized having advisors like
Kellyanne Conway has been normalized
treating our allies with disrespect as
some show of manhood has been normalized
it all has to be purged it only starts
with getting Trump out in November of
2020 let me know what you think I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
twitter at david pakman show if you love
learning new things you probably want to
check this out the david pakman show
today is sponsored by Skillshare and
we're giving you two entire months of
free access to Skillshare when you click
the link underneath this video
Skillshare is a vibrant online learning
community offering more than 25,000
video classes on just about anything you
can think of get better at playing an
instrument learn to use Photoshop how to
edit videos they have classes on drawing
painting business cooking nutrition
personal productivity and I'm not even
really scratching the surface I recently
took a great class on introductory
watercolour painting I'm still not good
but I am learning and you can access the
entire library of fun easy-to-use online
courses for free for two months by using
the link underneath this video two
months of learning something that's
totally new to you something you want to
get better at something you already love
or you can get ahead in your career by
learning new skills that will help you
at your job I've gotten a ton out of it
Pat has taken some courses that he's
found really valuable and I think you'll
love it to get started for free by
clicking the link under this video